Hello Pongfinity!
Hello, hello!
Hello everybody!
We are Pongfinity
Welcome to a new episode of Challenge Pongfinity
In this series you challenge us
with your crazy table tennis ideas
We have separated the table
We have one half here and the other 5 meters away
Good one!
That was quite low! Pretty good!
It's time to play with the chair.
The table is this way.
I thought it was that way.
I wasn't sure which way to have the chair!
It's not possible to hit so hard like this.
I won!
Now let's do one shot which each of the chair legs.
Just when I got them all!
Let's try the Xu Xin ball catch
With a non-chinese rubber.
It's okay.
There were a few bounces, it was not perfect.
We can do better!
There we have it!
The Xu Xin ball catch.
Yes.
Perfect catch.
With a wooden blade this should be a bit more difficult.
Not too bad.
Thanks for watching everybody!
Remember to subscribe here.
And watch our previous videos there.
Until next time!